thank you Yasser yes we are indeed with
Anish uh Anish first of all welcome back
to uh Bucharest how do you feel right
now re-energized you've watched the
world championship match what can you
tell us a bit about that yeah the match
was actually very inspiring uh I have to
say
so I was really looking forward to
glitches uh it's been a while I mean I
played a lot of Chess but not classical
so I'm you know quite excited and
sometimes you watch some tournaments and
they either you know slightly bring you
down or uh they inspire you and I think
what championship match was definitely
inspiring I'm not sure I mean it doesn't
mean that I'll play well but at least um
I'm looking forward to playing with that
give us a little a bit of insight of
what you were doing before because we
were you were posting on Instagram some
Seaside photos it looked like you were
maybe on a vacation maybe on a training
camp can you tell us anything about that
I mean at some point I was talking to
the uh to Vladimir kramik about these
things and you know it's of course
you're supposed to
work at the tournament prepare the
training camps and rest at the vacation
but um you know when you have a
you know an adult life like a grown-up
life let's say with the family and all
that sometimes responsibility that's
cool that's things like start turning
around and you like end up resting at
the tournament uh working hard on the
vacation and uh so I'm myself not sure
whether it was a holiday or or a
training camp but um
a lot of fun yeah a lot of fun I mean I
you know very motivated to work on chess
and
um now I'll have a lot of tournaments in
a row so I thought the time between
February where I played uh WR so I
played bike and WR Masters in a row and
then I had a couple of months um
so I thought it was a good time to you
know rest
and prepare a bit combine business and
pleasure yes of course of course tell us
about the game today
uh was actually one of those computer
generated variations
um
like that some players know probably
like this B5 you know I mean this at
some point was rare actually I came up
with this long long time ago when it
wasn't completely new so I was really
excited about it and I had this whole
line that I played today worked out but
then of course many other players also
found it because we'll use the same
tools and by now I think there are games
I think Jordan played this variation
I I would guess Dominguez I don't know
if he got this position but he's
probably was aiming for it right or yeah
you know well that one was B5 but I
think it's also played E5 Bishop before
but I'm not sure if you know say often
people want to play this but they don't
get to play it because let's say you
know some players play Bishop D2 here
and
so he played like literally the uh the
most fun line of all and the sequence I
mean from here the queen E7 a bit of d8
Queen C4 Bishop E6 couldn't 2.7 it's a
very serial sequence I think main move
here is Knight C4 according computer
okay this one it says um very high
Advantage for white but um a stronger
computer of course uh you know if you
let him run definitely felt like you're
still in Europe no I mean okay like yes
if you just keep moving forward at some
point you get some end game like not
even zeros but you get like um an end
game like a piece down but there are
like three pawns against one on one
flank and it's like 0.25
with the King Bishop against the kingdom
yeah exactly something like that Basics
actually
um is an alternative I
a very logical one I I don't know if he
was prepared or not I assume he was
prepared because he could play something
else at any point so which is safer but
yeah B6 was a nice practical so she was
also spending a lot of time yeah I don't
know whether he was trying to remember
or not and actually this position I've
um I think I've looked at it as well
um but I felt like actually over the
board I'm a little bit worse so I was
trying to remember what was the exact
variation because
um you know if we trade Queens for
example
I suspect that my position could be
close to lost because my apron can can
be lost in this four against three with
two Bishops on like let's say if you
traded a pair of Bishops
um or uh
yeah that's also like uh difficult I
don't know very hard and uh of course if
you trade the big pair of Bishops and I
give the 8.4 against three is draw
between the bishop pair I've seen even
sometimes even three against three
people I think swedler once lost against
uh in China some tournament so I
realized that I have to
um you know often you'll prepare and
then you realize what you prepared
during the game so I realized during the
game of the key I have to keep the
Queens on and I have to be active and
initially I like this Knight C5 idea
because it too very fancy then it goes
Queen B5 and I was thinking about this
kind of position Queen City to orbital
and I was thinking that you know
of course I have potential to go A5 and
all that so first of all I was not sure
what if Queen A7 but even even besides I
was not sure
um with this Knight MP3 is a little bit
like I'm banking a lot on that so I was
trying to play it a little bit
safer with Queen V8 and well I it looks
like the computer license so it's just
good I I think it was a little bit of a
safer move in a sense that I keep
coordination of my pieces I expect him
to play something like G3 try to keep it
then my idea is that in this position I
will go H6 or H5 then I have softened
him up quite a bit and it's a big deal
maybe I mean I mean it does feel like
the king is definitely much and likewise
if he goes H3 I suspect there's 96
Knight H5 ideas as well
yeah maybe you know it's also a little
bit weakening right let's say if he
tries to develop okay there are
different orders of the Knight H5 first
or the computer says G3 is prefers
connection to First
in this position prefers finish the
first but in any case it's clear I'm
generating some counter play and it's a
little bit more I found a little bit
more sound than with an item B3 yeah but
I the way he played I thought I
calculated that it's drawn you have to
calculate a few nice variations here so
first of all it's important somewhere
another screen D5 and I had um a bit of
a what do you mean you know about it you
haven't seen this position
I was calculating this and I now to be
honest with you
um this position in my file continues
for sure but I didn't recall because
very often you repeat so many lines and
your brain unnoticed it automatically
decides that okay this you will manage
yourself so don't remember and this is
one of those like sometimes when a
position looks very scary but here I
guess I thought that okay forget equal
material I'll manage myself you know so
I didn't remember I don't know maybe
Queen B8 is in my file it looks so nice
the company is so happy maybe it's in my
file but I felt like I came up with it
over the board I was happy with that in
any case yes here there were some nice
tactical variations
because of course I'm concerned that I
get thinned on the D file but here I
have connection for not Bishop E8 which
was also an idea ahead it's also okay
but I was thinking maybe 27 is a problem
here I was okay Bishop c5h6 as well but
daring but I was planning Queen H4 check
here and then um yeah it's easier and
then I just moved the bishop and uh at
some point I noticed the smooth Queen D5
got slightly panicky here because once
of course he gets the deadly Eternal pin
on the D file is tricky but I have Queen
H4 G3 G3 then I give a checklist
the bishop I want to move the rook and
ethical G4 H4 and The Rook is defended
again so yeah nothing works and Buster
Bishop G5 I was just for fun
um trying to see how many draws there
are like this thing maybe F6 also holds
um but I like 28 and here I think there
are multiple ways here I yeah I did it
very clinical but I think also the good
old could be it also works Bishop of
four Bishop E6 some very nice variations
here so it should be Bishop D5 is
drawing if Queen H5 if Queen H5 I have
internet so with H6 otherwise it should
be five
and if
[Music]
Queen H5 I have a nice move Queen to B2
Rook H1 H6 and if he takes an H6 I have
defending on that and then Bishop E5 I
have Queen to two and this is also draw
so so I like calculated all the possible
draws that are there and just okay one
for one of them I mean even right now it
feels like you are definitely looking
for a fight in this game maybe even in
this tournament what is the strategy in
I just want one more thing it's quite
kind of cute that you can blunder with
F6
um yeah because okay first of all Bishop
A7 King f8
Bishop
b878 but also uh Bishop D2 is also a
nice Bishop a5s yeah it's looking f8 is
no I was of course I'm looking uh
forward to play I also saw no
championship match you know you gotta
get a fight
because nowadays it's very hard to
to control the game as
it was the case before a well-prepared
players they could control the game
but nature of the game is such nowadays
that
um yeah you gotta get out there and
fight because um
you no longer have the advantage of
being better prepared because the it's
too easy to prepare now anybody without
any understanding or skills just looks
at the engine and before the engine
would give you let's say five options
and if you had some better understanding
you would see that okay the first option
is not good the second option is not
good but the third option is the right
one or the most sound one but now the
engines they are much more Superior and
they right away put that one that was
third then they will put on First with
the margin and so anybody just looks and
writes down the same lines and so um
yeah you don't have that edge anymore
that people used to have back in the day
and that means that you gotta find it
out behind the board I wish an
adventurous draw uh always great
insights thank you very much we'll see
you in the rest of the games
ah thank you Anis thank you Christian
and let's take a look at our result